a navy carrier group is sailing this
morning towards ninth North Korea the
country's official news agency just
warned the United States it may launch a
quote super mighty preemptive strike the
White House and Pentagon said last week
that the aircraft carrier Carl Vinson
was on its way to the region officials
now say that was a mistake a navy photo
from last weekend shows the Carl Vinson
thousands of miles away in Indonesia
headed south
instead of north major garrett is at the
white house with the attempt to explain
the error major good morning good
morning the administration as you noted
is on the defensive after a series of
misleading statements about the location
of that area that aircraft carrier
Strike Group and how its movements
either did or did not fit into the
strategic chess game with North Korea
the White House yesterday tried to shift
blame to the Pentagon while allies and
adversaries in Asia simply wondered
what's going on no comment from
President Trump about the burgeoning
crisis in North Korea but his secretary
of state and UN Ambassador turned up the
rhetorical heat on the volatile North
Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon we're
reviewing all the status of North Korea
both in terms of state sponsorship of
terrorism as well as all the other ways
in which we can bring pressure to bear
on the regime in Pyongyang the State
Department is now reevaluating president
george w bush's decision to lift the
state terrorism designation for North
Korea in 2008 an ill-fated effort to
deter the country's pursuit of nuclear
weapons the young leader of an
impoverished nation has an appetite for
grandiose propaganda a new video showed
Kim at a concert watching a simulated
video of a missile strike on the u.s. UN
Ambassador nikki Haley warned Pyongyang
to tread carefully telling reporters it
is important that North Korea know we
are not trying to pick a fight so don't
try to give us one but the White House
has to cope with its own mixed signals
last week the president and his press
secretary said the carrier USS Carl
Vinson and strike force vessels were
steaming toward the Korean Peninsula we
are sending an armada very powerful when
you see a carrier group steaming into an
area like that
the forward presence of that is clearly
through almost every instance a huge
deterrence but yesterday press secretary
Sean Spicer tried to clarify his remarks
we were asked a question about what
signal is sent we answered the question
on what signal is sent I'm not the one
who commented on timing when mr. Trump
spoke of the Armada the vessels were in
fact headed in the opposite direction
toward the Australian coast the Vinson
Strike Force is scheduled to arrive in
waters near the Korean Peninsula next
week news of the carrier groups actual
location triggered ridicule in South
Korea and China state-run media in China
and the South Korean press both accused
the administration of trafficking in
bluster and lies gale all right major
thank you